hello everyone welcome back to the
witching hour it is a very special
halloween edition of the show brought to
you by fx's original comedy what we do
in the shadows i'm perry this is haley
and we have so much fun stuff planned
right now in celebration of spooky
season that we do we are showing off
costumes we're talking to diana bang
from why the last man we're carving
pumpkins we were talking about our
favorite vampire movies and tv shows
which of course includes what we do in
the shadows yep and just in case you are
not familiar with what we do in the
shadows which you should be the fx
original comedy what we do in the
shadows documents the the daily or
nightly lives of four vampire roommates
who have lived together for hundreds of
years all episodes of season three are
now streaming on fx on hulu as well as
previous seasons
all right let's get into it
how are you doing i feel like i haven't
i haven't seen you in this setting in a
while
i've never seen you in this setting
before i guess so you know what i mean i
know in person and and dressed for i'm
schvitzing
thank you thank you i i felt like sam
was an appropriate costume to wear today
because of how much i love
trick-or-treat always always and if we
weren't in california that'd be
cozy unseasonably inappropriate i should
have thought about that but i didn't um
you're talking to a person with a neck
up to here right now all right that's
fair we're always on the same page
that's right
um
we have to like catch up too like
so spooky season has been going on for a
while i think it technically starts at
the beginning of september i'm like a
mid-september okay but yeah okay all
right i feel like that's a little more
reasonable than me but i go hard with
everything and like the first thing i
had to do i feel like you know what it
is
is it a coming up with a costume for
your little
bunny he dresses up and so i have a cat
named dewey and he dresses up he's a
good sport about it he hates costumes
but he usually does at least let me snap
a couple of pictures and i feel like
maybe we'll like show a picture when i
say what it is but this year
little deputy dewey is a shark
so i'm not entirely sure what i'm gonna
do with it yet but i feel like he's
either the shark from jaws or something
pertaining to king shark
just because the suicide squad is one of
my favorite movies of the year but
i'm like i can't quite figure out how to
photoshop him into something from the
suicide squad at the moment
oh now that's going to be a challenge
i'm going to think about
until we figure it out please please do
and please let me know when you have an
idea because i'm not creative enough for
this right now i can't wait to see
though those pictures are always a
highlight a seasonal highlight it is
just something else
what about halloween candy what have you
been eating
candy corn candy corn there's candy corn
fans in this room right yeah all right
i i do go in
i go in for candy corn but honestly like
uh
reese's always knocked me out in
halloween it's that's the one that gets
me if i had to pick the number one
halloween candy it would definitely be
like specifically a reese's peanut
butter cup like none of that reese's
piece is nonsense but i think my second
favorite is is probably candy corn like
i can eat a stupid amount of candy corn
i love it i don't get the hate but i i
have come to terms with the fact that
i'm also a person who likes pineapple
and pizza and i might just have bad food
opinions and i'm okay with it but it's
your food opinion so that makes it not
bad yeah that's correct everything i say
is right i've also gotten in the habit
of burning candy corn candles all the
time like i don't like any other scented
candle except for candy corn does it
actually smell like what does candy corn
smell like i mean it smells like it
smells like artificial candy corn just
like every candle does but i quite enjoy
it well that's fine that's seasonal you
know i love a seasonal candle yeah yeah
so so i am i'm sam without the mask
because we wouldn't dare ruin these
bangs um
i'm glad you enjoyed that
what what what inspired what do we see
today what is this
basically i was saying that but in a
nicer way what the heck is happening
here um
this is one portion of a costume that is
meant to be nadja from what we do in the
shadows
because i love it and me my boyfriend
are gonna be nadja and lazlo but um that
didn't happen i had i had several
conflicts that didn't come together the
fangs i got were too small for my teeth
and i have small teeth
uh
the dress was too large
and
the wigs are in storage they are not
available so instead i'm a just a
halloween spirit witch well this means
everybody out there is going to have to
check your social media at a point to
see the finished product that's right
because it's going to look it's going to
be exceptional i believe i believe i
have all the faith in the world
thankfully we do have a couple people in
studio today who have full costumes
like
oh hey oh hey my
movie club co-host
coy
i didn't traumatize you with our
halloween episode right i mean or did i
oh well now of my fear in a way that i
wasn't before i thought it might be a
childhood fear but you taught me as an
adulthood fear as well spooky movies are
scary guys
they're for some people like mayonnaise
they're not for everybody and like
mayonnaise they are very nutritious in
one way and horrific in others and
frankly i have no further places to go
with this mayonnaise metaphor except
that it's messy
like spooky movies i think i have
follow-ups let's talk more about
mayonnaise it goes on some sandwiches
yeah it goes in some genres it goes with
some things it doesn't go with others it
is a genre bender but always a bit slimy
it is always slimy i'll get you that so
i i struggle with harmfulness this is
like such a coy way of thinking through
things and i'm all for it oh now i'm
like i'm digging myself a
mayonnaise-filled hole i'm trying not to
get actively upset that you just
compared horror movies to mayonnaise
i feel like we're also making a lot of
people out there nauseous because don't
people like really hate mayonnaise
we're nailing it we're doing pineapple
on pizza candy corn and mayonnaise let's
see what else we do a lot of people
really love mayonnaise that's true like
there are zealots for mayonnaise i guess
i feel like that's my new band
this is a show for horror things so
people shouldn't be expecting good
advice in those categories from us
evergreen all right cory tell us what
you're wearing who are your dresses
right now you know i'm wearing uh vera
wang and frankly no i'm uh i'm peter b
parker because uh the quarantine was not
friendly to my uh other superhero
physiques and i love that i can be
myself while also being spider-man
thanks to peter b parker uh my favorite
thing was i remembered to bring
uh one different shoe so i actually do
have the found converse of peter b
parker
the matching socks was just me not not
being a good adult uh but peter b parker
ready for action
yes look at that attention to detail
that's
too perfect for oreos and beer and
happiness oh my what a koi tagline for
you all right thank you for showing off
your costume i think we have someone
else here
someone else with a with a very cool
costume i mean i don't want to play
favorites but this one might be at least
from a favorite movie yes
dorina
how you doing good hungry for boys you
got it
so tell everybody
who you are right yes i am jennifer
check from jennifer's body uh the
obviously the legendary megan fox i got
her a high school costume as well as a
little bit of blood here because you
know i'm
eating boys now but i used to eat boys
because you know that hell used to be a
teenage girl but now hal is actually a
middle-aged woman who's mexican and eats
corporate politicians
so yeah that's beautiful yeah it's going
to work that movie does not get nearly
enough oh my god oh you brought this you
guys gotta zoom in i don't know yeah i
got my little jennifer's body light
where did you get that on the etsy oh
really yeah i guess you could probably
find anything
don't do that makes me nervous
i was half expecting like you to have
prepped your tongue with some flammable
something
i know what if i just lift the studio on
fire please don't do that no let's not
do that but you nailed it
yeah it's a good movie it's underrated
not a lot of people know it highly
recommend watching it karen kusama yes
excellent makes one good movie after the
next and like two great performances
from uh megan fox and amanda seifried
exactly even kyle galliner we love kyle
gowner on this show stolen supremacy
so
really good
all right i think uh i think you nailed
it you're fully in character we love you
and we're going to see you in a little
bit yes
goodbye dorina and hello
to the browiest person i know and i feel
like i could say that because you're
really really leaning into it right now
dude bro party massacre match yes of
course
these are both mine these aren't perfect
i'm not sharing no no it's a dude bro
donato i respect the rules dot not toe
bomb party massacre three
oh boy wait so i i have a feeling a lot
of people out there might not know what
your outfit pertains to right now so
just just in case that's the case please
please tell them what dude bro party
massacre is
duper party
no three
even though the first two don't exist uh
dude no you haven't told me that a
million times dude of operative master
iii is one of the funniest i i think
it's one of the best satires on
nostalgia right now that we have and i
talk into the mic
duper party massacre 3 is one of the
best nostalgia commentaries we have
right now it's a great satire to great
spoof but what it does best is still
bring the slasher into the modern genre
somehow through all the dew growiness
and through all of the
beer bongs and kills and things of that
nature like it is just straight bros
being bros the whole movie but it's in
place of a sorority house massacre so
like
it's
it's really smart and i know i'm saying
that about a movie called dubra party
massacre 3 but like yes i and the first
two don't exist in case you uh don't go
looking for one and two they don't exist
at all this is a fake movie
oh man it is so good i have a question
yes does your quarantine hair make you
an even more like an even better dude
massacre party three
costume it had volume before i got here
and it took me so long to get here that
all my volume went away like that heat
again
you killed me but so i i guess it does
it it goes more into the uh long-haired
bro vibe of the 80s
for sure in any case i'm not playing
flannel bro i'm not playing turtleneck
bro because those are real characters in
the movie i am just random bro number
three
i'm all for this this is what i've done
this is what you brought me on to do so
guess what i'm doing you are exactly
right
i'm not gonna let this i'm gonna be
thinking about this for the rest of the
show yes i will be as well
all right i think we have one more
person right i think like like someone
else is here i don't know who this is
though
someone someone
you know i love halloween
and i thought
in loving halloween one can't just wear
one costume because that would be
short-sighted so instead
you bring the most wholesome superhero
and also represent
the most wholesome show on television
with a custom jersey uh my birthday is
september 15th i weighed five pounds 15
ounces and was born at 5 15 p.m so 15 is
my lucky number and i don't know what
that means in soccer because i don't
sports but that is certainly my position
so genre 15 ted lasso jersey ted lasso
i also where do you even get that uh you
know they they custom make them the the
girl i'm seeing got it for me for my
birthday and so that was on the 15th so
she uh she ordered it excellent so like
i'm now i'm on i'm on afc richmond i did
it all right i made the team i like that
you went from like i'm fully quarantined
up i'm just a normal i'm a normal
spider-man i'm an
i'm a athlete athlete in the last 12
minutes
i did a lot of cardio
everything has changed beer remains
you're wearing them both i feel like
peter parker would appreciate a nice and
so would ted lasso the sports fans so i
appreciate it that's true it's like
continuity
very very impressed with a quick costume
change all right so that's it for our
costume segment you know where we have
to go next you can stay here for this
time to leave before so we got a lot we
got a lot to get to right now because
it's it's halloween and you need to cram
in as many horror movies as humanly
possible but more specifically we want
to lean into the vampire of it all right
now and we have so much good content
that you need to check out and
haley and i were going to save our
recommendations for last but we have
someone returning to the show who's got
a very good one for you i can confirm i
know what he picked welcome back to the
show koi
i'm so excited what you got for us what
is what is your must watch a vampire
movie of choice for this halloween
season blind boys don't lie
cry little sister
sax solo the lost boys is not just the
vampire movie it's the
80s movie if you like happiness you like
the lost boys this movie is pure
jubilant
jolly
jovial joy this movie is just so much
and it captures the
sardonic cheese of a classic horror film
while mixing in pop culture references
which are now almost not dated because
we're bringing them back like we're so
into the 80s culture they're not like
dated references they're like oh yeah of
course and it does all of this while
influencing i would argue buffy
most modern uh slightly slapstick cheesy
horror films in general and gives us
jason patrick kiefer sutherland and the
coreys this movie is cinema i can watch
it daily i watch it far too often i'm
not a horror guy but this movie is
it's like calling uh i don't know
godfather a mafia movie it is cinema yes
the lost boys is the godfather of
vampire movies maybe better koi what
town does it take place in it takes
place in santa carla i know which i know
that perhaps not santa clara but close i
said santa cruz it's not santa cruz
which is real but where it was filmed
where i went to school yes
that's why i said it it's like a capital
of the world
no it's actually quite lovely
it's
grandpa misled me also the grandpa in
that film i would argue is one of the
greatest of any character actor moments
like the way this film wraps up the way
the grandpa navigates everything like i
just i we just do an hour on the lost
boys i'm taking over the show i'm sorry
to everything else it's the lost boys
that's what movie club is for can we do
an entirely lost boys episode i'd be
down for it i'd let's talk about the
loss yeah all right
i'll be back i feel like i don't know it
nearly as well as you do but i do love
it and i watch it every once in a while
it's also amazing to run to the
soundtrack is incredible because you'll
be listening to like these crazy rock
ballads and they'll just be like so much
sexy sexy sex so much oh god it is
sexual
get on it get on the lost boys
all right
thank you for that one question
[Laughter]
we've got
dorina coming back yay
with her own pick for a must-watch
vampire movie this season
oh hi hello there this is my favorite
sandwich i've ever been in the middle of
i get it i get it
all right ladies so we're going to talk
about the best vampire movie ever made
as i agree with koi that lost voice is
amazing however in 1992 i was 10 years
old when i saw this movie
which is by the way academy
award-winning movie
with one of the best most towering
terrifying performances as dracula by
gary oldman and that is bram stoker's
dracula which also
i know
not everybody loves it however keanu
reeves his british accent i think should
have also won an oscar because it is
hilarious and so this movie has it all
it has amazing costume design and
amazing makeup an amazing cinematography
uh by the great michael baja bauhaus i
believe who uh work with scorsese it's
got it all and also winona ryder asmina
harker obviously and keanu rose's
jonathan harker doing a british exit
badly terribly but it's so funny so when
you're terrified as a kid watching this
movie you're also laughing at the same
time i think it's wonderful i think that
was a wonderful pitch
i i agree and you know what when you
really love something i think you see
the good and the bad is both beautiful
exactly i clearly love this movie truly
which i do too i mean look it also has
an amazing score well uh well shaquillar
i still can't say his name but it's one
of the coolest theme songs ever from
like a horror movie and you know your
scores i do i really do pairing now
we've had long conversations about that
yes that's the only time i get invited
to colliders to talk about scores which
i'm happy to do no i'm kidding uh but um
yeah i think it's freaking great and i
think everybody should watch and even if
you think it's cheesy and yes the
romance gets a little bit you know it's
not for me as much it still looks
amazing it's visually stunning movie
like they don't make movies like that
anymore shout out to francis ford
coppola
also correct i forgot to mention annie
lennox sings the uncritic songs so you
can't lose there there's a whole lot of
pluses there so many that's a lot to
love and i like that you brought up the
keanu reeves accent because maybe you're
not the biggest vampire person maybe
you're just dipping your toes in but
like if you love keanu reeves that's
something to see and it might bring you
to braum stoker's dracula and everybody
should eventually be brought to braum
stoker's dracula agreed i know where the
bus that sleeps
thank you for that
all right we have one more all right and
yet again mr matt donato is doing
something very on brand with his pick
knocking
so
do i dare ask what you have for us today
so you've heard classics so far uh what
i'm going to bring you is streaming on
amazon prime so i want to say that right
now you can stream it it's a little
lesser known vampire flick it is also a
rock musical so i'm throwing a vampire
rock musical your way it is called suck
it played tiff it played south by
southwest in the late 2000s and from
there
do you guys know what suck is
do not i do i have i only know it
because you bring it up every once in a
while as you can see it's under seen so
suck is a lesser known vampire rock
comedy it is written directed and partly
composed by rav stefaniak and
he does so much to bring the road
element of a band called wait for it the
winners
they are not the winners when the movie
starts out so it is a lesser known band
they get on the road they meet alice
cooper who is a bartender who might also
be the devil moby plays a metal head who
throws meat at crowds
and then they meet someone who's vampire
and the vampire gives some of them
powers and slowly one by one they start
turning into vampires and they become ex
super famous as vampire so the moral
conundrum becomes do i accept fame for
selling my soul
or do i stay human and not really that
important
the most straightforward metaphor yeah
who hasn't debated that i was going to
say what's your answer to that oh
vampire in a minute like not even no
hesitation i think i'd have that same
problem if i can be famous if i can be a
rock star and also be like immortal and
super vampire sexy yeah
i think that's very fair i don't judge
you for that choice whatsoever i feel
like for me it would be like
being famous would be the thing you had
to accept to be a vampire instead of
reverse
all right that's fair i have to be
famous but i get to be a vampire okay
fine what if i tell you you're hunted by
malcolm mcdowell whose name is eddie van
helsing in the movie in obviously
exactly right
i don't think that changes anything yeah
all the jokes are on the nose it is not
doing anything it's like trying to be
highbrow or anything of that nature it's
just really fun and the music is kind of
catchy so like the last thing i'll say
is i'm a sucker for any movie that tells
a story through this week
so i'm a sucker for suck yes
all right
i'm gonna leave on that put that on the
dvd box
retroactively a decade later
so we have some some stuff of our own to
cover yeah i know you got a big one
oh yeah you mean like one of the best
shows ever made of all time ever in the
history of television
i will agree with that i don't know it
as well like i haven't re-watched this
show nearly as much as i think you have
but i'm still very much behind the
statement you just made inspired by the
lost boys
fair enough you can
we can go down that road a million years
it's inspired it's
any day it's inspired by a lot of things
uh it is buffy the vampire slayer it is
the formative i wouldn't even say
television show like piece of
entertainment of my youth
every
week tuned in when i was a kid just like
had to see the next episode and
uh aside from why i love it because it
does get quite expansive in mythology
it's not just vampires it goes
everywhere but really
inspired by lost boys let's say
in its irreverent approach to vampirism
and uh power
and just
one of the most clever things i i think
ever put on the air it it
even if oh i'm getting so deep in the
weeds in my mind but like when it comes
to the vampires because things start out
semi-simple and the moralism but you've
got angel who's like the good broody
vampire but once the show goes on it's a
seven season show and it just really
evolves that sense of morality spike
fans now
uh it is
the best show ever and i love it and you
should watch it and yeah watch it for
vampires but just watch it because it's
the best ever the person next to me on
the plane on the way back to la recently
was watching it and i was doing that
like creeper thing where i'm looking at
her laptop and i couldn't stop because
that show it sucks away
what's the the silent one that was
always my favorite so hush hush is the
only episode that i watched like over
and over and over phenomenal no speaking
for most of the episode uh not vampire
centric episode but one of the best and
that's what i mean by like the the
mythology just expands so much
horrifying in the best possible way
genuinely scary yeah it really is all
right i have something that is not
genuinely scary so we really can't do
this show without highlighting of course
what we do in the shadows the show which
like from the bottom of my heart like i
adore that show it is excellent and it
has been inspired by
an excellent movie what we do in the
shadows the film is fantastic and
yes i know it's not shaky camera found
footage but in general i always love
when the cinematography can do something
different to add to the story and the
mockumentary approach to telling the
story of a bunch of vampires who live
together is just genius the way that
they play into it the comedy like the
way the whole thing is shot i really do
think amplifies all that so so well and
it you know it basically gave us
something that we've never seen before
because how many times like whether
we're talking about
i don't know like vampires or zombies or
just like name your really popular
cinematic supernatural creature how many
times have we had the conversation where
it's like this has been done to death i
am sick of it don't do it anymore this
is an example of a movie that takes
something that you have seen a lot of on
the big screen and does something very
different with it and it does it very
well
yes
it does and it's like
you kind of pulled my head in an
interesting direction when you were
saying them because when this film came
out like vampires weren't the thing
anymore they were in a vampires go in
cycles of popularity and it was on a
downtrend and this just totally broke
through regardless of the public
sentiment and a lot of that obviously is
due to like tiger ytd and jermaine
clement's uh incredibly sharp writing
and performance skills and generally
their sense of humor which
uh
when you say it's not
the scary it's like no it's not it's a
it's a comedy but it is
quite something in the way they approach
the the effects when it does get a bit
bloody they hit a really unique balance
in their writing between this isn't
quite scary but oh man that got a little
real for a minute yep all right speaking
of not so scary but like kind of scared
this was scary for me as a kid a little
bit we've got one more that we want to
throw out there and it isn't necessarily
a straightforward uh vampire film but
it's it's one of the most important
halloween viewing essentials out there
you cannot have a halloween without
incorporating this movie at some point
and it's hocus pocus of course i
watched that movie more times than i can
count as a kid and i still to this day
can quote it over and over i watch it
every halloween season i adore it i
adore doug jones in it
we don't talk about how good doug jones
is in that movie and everything he's in
for that matter
but
i can still quote this whole thing i
adore the sanderson sisters i know that
i would be the jerk to light the black
flame candle and i'm totally okay with
that
it's it's essential this movie is so a
part of my life i can't even describe it
i echo everything you just said clearly
i'm here for which culture yes yes uh
but you know there is that vampire
thread the dad does
the vampire at the party and he rocks it
they are having a good time
uh he is loving being a vampire for that
night maybe loving it too much who could
say
i i fully adore hocus pocus and i've had
a lot of
fun showing it to weirdly people who
hadn't seen it that does happen like
adults yes oh wow uh and they're just
forever charmed it's a forever charming
film i can't wait until my niece is
like
i don't know like i'm a bad judge of
what's appropriate for a child to watch
so nobody listened to me on this but the
main reason why i don't show it to her
right now is because she just doesn't
have the attention span to watch a full
feature and how old is it she's two oh
that's she's not good yeah she's she's
busy watching all the cartoons right now
in like three years i know she'll be
able to i'm impatient i want to share
everything i love with her now she just
won't remember it
that's the thing i'll be patient and
i'll wait but to everybody out there
hocus pocus is an absolute must-watch
this season you have to check it out
hey
thanks for having me so excited to have
you and so excited that you dressed for
the show no i heard it was a party so i
was like okay not to allison man gotta
gotta dress up as
the mad scientist slash bill nye i don't
know
tis too perfect let's talk a little bit
about spooky season are you a big fan in
general do you usually go big with
halloween plans and costumes and
everything
it depends on the year depends on i'm
fairly lazy so when it comes to costume
planning it's sort of a last-minute kind
of
thing i think my my go-to is um
finding what color of clothing do i have
a lot of okay do i have any wigs
that are the same color and then i'll
like um
so let's just say i have blue wig blue
clothes i'll go i'll be like okay go
online print out like a windex product
like windex label and i'll just like
paste it on myself so i do that every
year i'm like okay i got a lot of red
okay i'm gonna be ketchup this year and
then other years it's like mustard oh
i'm gonna be silver or nickel or yeah i
don't know i was asked did you already
have this style and tie
this is mine i went through this like
love of diane keaton phase when i was
younger and you know
just tried to dress like her but
couldn't pull it off so this is from way
back and so yeah
i pulled it out
perfect very good thing to have on hand
uh what are what are the big halloween
plans this year anything in particular
for day of
i mean not yet i'm hoping that i can um
go visit
a friend with kids and you know probably
tag along when they go trick-or-treating
uh if they go trick-or-treating or if
not then just hang out and uh hopefully
give out candy or you know what about
you two do you have any cool plans
that's that's a very good question we
were trying to cook up a little
something the other day but
a top priority for me before the holiday
actually hits is to visit another one of
the many los angeles haunts i love
haunted houses and being scared so get
me in one of those again and i'mma be a
happy person are they open oh they are
open they are up and running and they
are quite wonderful
oh
okay
that's exciting i i don't know if we
have any haunted houses i'm in vancouver
right now so
maybe usually they have this sort of
this like um
uh
this like
where they have the fair they have these
haunted like
you know places you can go in and get
scared they freak me out too much i went
i went one year and i was like okay i'm
good i'm good
good follow-up to that then what about
horror movies in general do they freak
you out too much or are you into them
they do freak me out so when i remember
when i was little i watched um you know
like some of the friday the 13th stuff
and like chucky
and
um
like children of the corn poltergeist i
that stuff freak
freaked me out a lot and so i'd watch
them with my older cousins
and then not be able to sleep obviously
um
yeah so
and then as i got older um i like the
more campy stuff um
you know i'm pretty basic when it comes
to horror like knowledge and horror
stuff so i'm sure i can learn a lot more
from the both of you but i saw ginger
snaps fairly recently
which
so good i love that so good
and like coming of age together and like
kind of becoming a monster but like also
embracing the monster i don't know i'm
that was um
i loved it and i and this is like a
little bit of a name drop but i got to
work with uh catherine
isabelle on a show
and she's fantastic so
i was like
i think if i watched it before i worked
with her i would have fangirled so bad
she's like she's something of a horror
queen i feel like that's you definitely
learn a lot about horror from catherine
as well
yeah she's super vampy in real life too
just like you know cat-like and vampy
i'm like ooh i want to hang out with you
more
she's really cool too cool
i feel like um
so something that's not too spooky for
anyone during the season is what's your
like what's your essential halloween
candy what's the one you gotta have when
it's halloween
oh
uh
you know what i hated though when i grew
like i can tell you what i hate it is
those caramels you know everyone does
every anyone like them you know the
caramels with the
with the uh halloween wrappers i don't
know if you know what i'm talking about
is it like the the little like wax
wrapper type thing yeah
did you like those those are terrible
i'm terrified of the dentist so i will
not eat anything that could potentially
pull my teeth or fillings out
oh okay
that's a good call i should probably do
that myself
i think i'm a little extreme about it to
be fair
yeah
what what what do you like to eat
so i think i'm in the minority on this
because i know it's a big debate but i'm
obsessed with candy corn
i love you know
i like how they look
they're very pretty you know like in
little little plastic baggies like
there's
like it's like a nice gift that you
don't want
candy corn is definitely the seasonal
obsession but if i had to pick the
number one halloween candy it is
obviously reese's peanut butter cups it
doesn't really get any better than that
i was gonna say potentially reese's as
well i also like um
i like wonder bars i don't know and
wonder bars yeah what is a wonder bar
why do i not know what that is
do you not have that in the states maybe
it's a canadian thing
no it's i think we have them
okay well i probably because they're
chewy so yeah i'm just gonna say they're
not here
yeah
they're like uh you know it's um
they're chewy so they got a little bit
of the caramel i think they've got some
like
peanut buttery stuff as well and like
some crunchy bits
i don't know it's really good i used to
give it to people and be like you're
wonderful
here's a wonder bar so cheesy
here here's another uh question that'll
come up later on in this witching hour
episode how would you rate your pumpkin
carving skills are you any good at it
um
i pretend that i'm good at it no i mean
every time we i would do the
every time we'd have those like contests
you know the the pumpkins that are
barfing you know like
yes that was my go-to my go-to is like
yes i'm gonna win this by carving out
the largest mouth
picking out the insides and like having
it barf out like the more um kind of
like
gross-ish or pukish or um like
that i could make um a pumpkin that was
yeah just it's it's never really
delicate you know how there are those
pumpkins that are so beautiful like
i don't know uh
i
that i've seen on the streets at least
um with like the beautiful witches and
um
obviously they're uh they took a lot of
care to carve them out and uh that's not
for me i'm just like that
square i mean triangle eyes big mouth
and it barf there
winner
i feel i feel like we might all be on
the same level here really i think so
i like to do the fancy ones but it takes
so much time and like preparation if i'm
on the spot and i just have to carve a
face maybe not so good maybe not
how long how long how long would you sit
there trying to carve these fancy
pumpkins oh gosh i'm so over the top so
we had a halloween party like two years
ago where i wanted to do a pumpkin
display i think i spent it wasn't one
pumpkin but i carved like 10 different
pumpkins i think i was there for like
four or five hours like way over the top
halloween nerds
yeah but four or five hours is pretty
good for like that's like half an hour
per pumpkin that's i that's pretty good
yeah i'm also cheating a little bit
because i'm not counting the time i
spent like the day before pre-poking the
outline of where i was gonna carve i'll
say this
stretch your wrists that's a lot if
you're going in for the detailed ones
yeah
yeah like carpal tunnel syndrome yeah
how did you get your purple channel all
from carving too many fancy pumpkins
it's a way better story than sitting on
the computer
it's true that's true
all right let's get into why the last
man because the show is excellent and
you are something else in it i mean that
from the bottom of my heart
i wanted to start with the very
beginning of your casting process
because
olivia thoroughly was on one of our
shows and she was explaining that like
it was a bit of a of a quick whirlwind
where she was cast and then all of a
sudden she was up there shooting so was
it the same thing for you did you score
the role and then immediately get
whisked off to start filming
um no my my story's a little bit
different um
basically i
uh i put the role on tape
uh i got a call back i flew myself down
to la
um
you know took that risk and then uh
ended up getting the part
uh but
because my character um shows up kind of
halfway through the season
so i
was at home
uh i was about to go to uh toronto to go
just meet everyone um at the very
beginning but then obviously the
pandemic hit
um
yeah so that was that so i did i did a
lot of waiting around at home but i will
say so eli uh clark is a showrunner she
is
honestly the most wonderful i i'm sure
olivia just went into how
awesome she is and how like we joke that
she's like so pathologically inclusive
and she is so
just thoughtful and like
i felt so respected and heard being a
part of that show and she it's because
she was at the helm so
um
with her at the helm she kind of
organized these like zoom meetups so
we'd meet up like
i don't know
um
once every few weeks just online and we
just hang for like an hour and just chat
and that was really cool so i i did feel
like i was a part of the team even
though
i didn't show up until like
way like months and months later uh
yeah so
it's um
yeah it was it was a lot of sitting
around but i i still felt like i was a
part of the process
so that was nice
that is such a nice uh part of it to
have so you were involved like before
the pandemic started okay okay
it's it's interesting to hear the
stories about how you know like the show
was ready to go before the pandemic and
then everything came to a screeching
halt and some things changed and i think
it was late 2020 and then or did i just
fast forward a bit no it was late 2020
wow
when what
when uh additional people started to get
brought into the ensemble and then
immediately after that it was jumping
into shooting wow i don't think i
actually computed how quickly you guys
did that and then shot the show and then
it came out for us
it was the quickest turnaround ever
we're like uh
um
uh eli shared a lot some of the episodes
with us before and we're like we just
shot this a month ago
it was it was a little bit weird
something else
had you guys already completed filming
then by the time it premiered or were
you still wrapping up
no by the time it premiered we were done
we stopped we we were finished by
mid-july i think and then
um
yeah it premiered mid-september
it's pretty fast for a whole season
of television
yeah it was really fast i mean they shot
the pilot the year before
um yeah end of 2020
so i guess i don't know maybe
uh
i don't know we were ready to go but
like early 2020 so maybe they were just
like chomping at the bit they're like
hey let's get this out
yeah
so
this is obviously based on source
material that many out there absolutely
adore so when you jump into a role like
this how do you find the balance between
respecting that source material and the
character that fans already know and
love but then adding your adding your
own bits to it making her your own for
this show
yeah um
you know i hadn't read the source
material until i auditioned for it and
then
um
when i got the role obviously i finished
it uh and
so i wanted to add like bits of her like
sort of her essence um and you know some
of that like kind of prickly
kind of cantankerous side as uh you kind
of see in the comics
uh
but when i talked to um
eli
uh
she kind of wanted to go past the
sort of typical scientist trope and
really uh flesh allison out you know
she's
not just some like person kind of an
unfeeling sort of person who comes in
and you know says her sciency jargon and
then leaves
she is you know a full human she's
passionate she's charismatic she is you
know full of energy she's got like she's
complex she's
controversial i think there's
so
much to allison that
um we have yet to learn i'm you know i'd
be so excited to kind of dig even deeper
into her sort of
back story and like what has um
like what she's been through and uh yeah
and sort of how her relationships kind
of continue with both 355 and yorick
so that'll be really exciting um
yeah i i just want to make allison uh
yeah again a three-dimensional character
that's that's what that's my hope
um
and i think with eli at the helm uh
that's not gonna be a problem
you are very very successful in what you
just described i feel i'm i mean it
honestly i feel like everything you just
described is what i saw and felt while
watching it and i love the dynamic
between the three of them
oh yay thank you
was there anything uh specific uh that
you took away from those conversations
with eli that was like um
that felt either or different to the
source material or framed things in a
new way that really helped you um come
to set like
with a firm grasp on this take of the
character
um i think it's like
learning as i go i think because the um
you know there's this cataclysmic event
that happens and i think in that
you know you do sort of lose a sense of
yourself and you question who am i you
know like what identity stay what
identities go and i think for me i was
just like trying to go go um on the ride
and kind of discover allison as i you
know as i went through each episode and
so i was open to kind of discovering um
different sides of her which you'll see
more of in uh the last couple of
episodes which you know
please watch because it it ramps up
quite a bit and it gets it's really
exciting i don't know
uh
i don't know when you're releasing this
but episode 8 is out right now and
episode 8 is i when i read that script i
was just like ah
i cannot wait to see this and when i
actually saw it i was so pumped at the
end
i
i don't even know i was like i need to
watch episodes nine and ten right now
i'm like bursting right now wanting to
talk about them i might have watched
them last night and they are something
else yes
i need
more
i know
you watched all um did you i watched i
watched the whole season you got the
whole season
i've been blabbing to haley as i've been
cruising through and i keep saying how
much i love it and the way you guys just
stuck the landing and teed up some
things that i need to see more of it's
just
more people need to watch this show
please listen alright
um let's highlight ben and ashley a
little because again your dynamic is one
of my favorite qualities of the show so
let's get nice and convoluted with this
with your collaboration process what is
something that all three of you like to
do that made that collaboration easy and
seamless and then what's something
unique that each of you brought to that
process
um
so what's surprising is that we actually
didn't have a chemistry read before we
got the part uh
it just sort of i think it's in the
writing you know and i think it's also
eli's vision she was
uh probably there in all of the audition
rooms like during the um
she was there when i did my call back
and i'm sure she met with obviously
ashley and ben
uh
so
honestly
a lot of it's in the writing um
and
for us i think we got together once
before um we actually shot the first
scene that i appear in just so that we
could
get the rhythm and the timing because
that's you know a part of it too like
that sort of um
the quick back banter back and forth um
yeah i think we just
found our way i think for me when i
first showed up i was just like
because i was chomping at the bit right
i was like waiting and i came and i was
like
and i just was like running around i
think all that pent up energy i mean
same with allison i was
and i think for probably ben and ashley
they're like oh okay but it worked for
355 and you're like who is this lady
just you know
wielding a knife and
screaming at us um
yeah i think i don't know what it
i can't point to a specific
thing that we did i just think it
happened like sometimes the chemistry is
there and sometimes it isn't and for us
luckily it was there
i think we all just really
dove deep into our characters you know
and um
really thought about sort of like the
relationships i think what in terms of
um a good trio i think
um
we're
i think what's important is that we're
able to cycle through different
archetypes as well you know sometimes
i'm like a sister sometimes i'm like the
wife sometimes i'm the mother some you
know and i think you can see that with
the trio like we cycle through kind of
archetypes and relationships and like
depending on the situation and the
context and i think that's really
important um and i just think we're very
yeah we're just distinct uh the
characters are just distinct
so
yeah i don't know
the i think it's eli and the casting i
don't know i i'll
that's what i that's where
i'll put the um i'll chalk it up too in
terms of the chemistry
totally makes sense i hear you yeah
diana thank you so much for joining us
and happy halloween to you happy
halloween thank you and again congrats
on crushing the costume game today
thank you
all right
welcome back
to the studio where we are about to
carve some pumpkins
vampire themed pumpkins if we can
accomplish it
i'm gonna be lucky if i could carve like
the simplest face imaginable into this
pumpkin right now you're gonna do great
what is that how are you even doing that
i'm not doing that
you cut this stuff off so when you put
your you know candles or whatnot my
rings off it doesn't burn
you can
cook all these seeds into a tasty treat
and i haven't tried this yet but it was
like
before getting like something pattern i
don't know this seems like a lie
i'm not getting any traction here
whatsoever
oh it sounds like stringing in
i feel like i've here
this feels like the easier part to me
it's like the the actual carving that
i'm gonna have a hard time with i'm
gonna do that
it's very low stakes enterprise fair
i feel like i should just use my hands
i often do my god i'm just gonna
get in there
grab it
you know so try this little guy i
haven't had what is that it's supposed
to help you get all these looks like a
cooking tool and you know i don't know
how to use
does it have to be like completely clean
that we really should have gotten paper
towels
next halloween we're prepping pumpkins
and we are buying paper towels do i have
to get all the stringy bits out too or
just the same
ideally you want to get as many of the
long ones out so when you put a candle
in it they don't catch on fire
but for this one i'll work a little
harder then
this is like
not easy oh and the other thing
takes me a really long time to carve a
pumpkin up to my liking because the
other thing is if you start cutting out
faces and you have all these stringies
on there they're gonna kind of show
through whatever you cut out like i've
got a ton of stringies in here
these are not the french pumpkins i'm
gonna be honest is that is that why the
strawberry
they're stringier than goofy i i feel
ashamed that i've spent all this time in
the garden and i don't know how to pick
a fresh pumpkin but i've never found
them you still probably would have done
a way better job than i would
[Music]
is it a dumb idea to try to use the
knife to cut some of the strings no
[Music]
it's just it's just a plant
we got bunk pumpkins man we're gonna be
here all day if i cut all these
stringies off yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't
get that focused
so what part are you up to you're still
emptying your pumpkin i am when you when
you start the next phase i'll stop with
the strings my main thing is i want to
get all my seeds out and i'm not quite
there yet
like do you legit have to get every seed
out i mean i try to but that's because i
like to make them into a tasty treat all
right i feel like nothing bad happened
you don't get a curse on your house i
don't know you told me that the stringy
set things on fire so i don't want like
this
i am not a fire safety professional i
can either confirm or deny the strings
or importance these were a mistake oh no
chucky no oh look at that progress
progress made
so are you just going to like freehand
this well you can i think these little
clap clowns crayons are to like help you
sketch out what you want
i guarantee you i forget to carve that
part out and i just wind up hacking up
the triangles
what do i do with the mouth that's not
going to be impossible for me
too give him like a vampire cheese
that's it
i feel like this drawing is crap but
it's gonna look way better it's gonna
look so good it's gonna look better than
mine i take like pumpkin carving too
seriously so without like my proper
tools this is gonna be a disaster is
this the tool to use to cut it or is
there another tool on this table it
feels like this thing is gonna break
it's just good television barry
which was the detail one
the little like the little
guy is that this one
[Music]
okay let me just see if i can
make it go in a circle look i did it
and i gave him like
you did awesome there's like a lot of
strength
i think you're treating this like a
competitive sport
and it's really just the thing you do
for fun
wait
[Music]
okay
i'm like
not following the lines anymore
carve your own path never colored in the
lines
pretty good
i feel like we're gonna have to turn out
the lights to get the full effect after
yeah
but isn't that always true
i meant specifically of pumpkins but i
guess it sounded like i was talking
about life
you put me down like a rabbit hole of
thought with that comment
these are not the sturdiest knives
they are not that is true
they're for children
really because i still feel very
dangerous holding it
children under parental
supervision you're my supervision right
now make sure i don't do anything stupid
oh i'm the wrong person
i love stupid stuff
look at that it's happening
i'm so close
oh it's happening it's happening
it's kind of happening there it goes
hey
he's got bangs
definitely i'm so mad
definitely should have bought paper
towels
i think that's the biggest lesson i've
learned right it's a really valuable
lesson for everyone at home buy paper
towels first
it's just it's not working the mouth is
not working
all right i'm gonna rethink the mouth
where's your little like spinny mixer
thing spinning mixer thing
okay
and you do
oh god i like don't even have the hand
power to turn this
what are you doing with it it's like you
seem
clear that that's i again i'm not
convinced it's hyper effective
i don't think that's helping me i think
it's a more more of a me problem though
like i just can't i'm not sure about
that
oh look it's like it just puked
yep
i feel like i'm so close
like it's
it's not that bad
it's just very messy
we need to
clean up
i'm so sorry
i will pick all of that up
[Music]
hey matt can i ask you one other favor
can you grab my watch and my rings and
take them off the table
they're right here
i really underestimated how messy this
was
yours looks like a bat i was really
stunned to see we were doing it here on
the recording table i'm going to be
honest i brought like a whole bunch of
like
um things to lay out on the floor
because it's so messy
i didn't even think about that thank you
matt
all right he lost his top teeth in a
vampire tribunal according to um true
blood rules okay i'd believe it
so do you snap the glowy sticks and then
put it in the pumpkin you do
nonsense of halloween colors nonsense
i feel like it'll look good when we turn
out the lights
that's what i'm telling you you need to
wipe your hands
oh thank you
oh so close so crack this and just stick
it in yeah i mean let's see how that
works
wild tops
that looks really good
i'm so
spooky stuff
look at that classic gentle gentle
jack-o'-lantern
with a with a little vampire twist yeah
look at that bat
look at this
absurdist art representation of a
pumpkin
cheers with pumpkin guts
we did it we did it cheers
don't drink that don't
look i clean this whole set with the
snap of my fingers and with haley's
witch fingers
that's the power we have together it's
magic it's magic during spooky season
and with that i think that brings us to
the end of this edition of the witching
hour
thank you so much to diana and to our
wonderful guests for swinging by and
telling us about some of their favorite
vampire movies and showing off their
super cool costumes it was great and
thank you to fx's what we do in the
shadows for sponsoring this spooky
halloween episode and be sure to catch
all the episodes of season three now
streaming on fx on hulu and be sure to
keep an eye out for season four which is
in production now
and you can learn more at
fxnetworks.com and on social at the
shadows fx and with that we are out of
here happy halloween everybody you have
officially survived the witching hour